[Music]
in this video we'll dive into Google
Cloud console interactive tutorials
interactive tutorials are a step-by-step
tutorial that can help you learn about
Google Cloud they are embedded directly
into the Google Cloud console so there
is no contact switching they have a
feature that we call spotlights to help
guide you users around the UI
but more on that leader
finally these tutorials integrate with
Cloud shell and Cloud code to provide a
pre-configured development environment
not only do users have interactive
tutorials to help them on their Learning
Journey the when users click the learn
button a panel appears that displays
relevant links to documentation for the
current page this panel is called learn
assistant learn assistant not only
provides additional interactive
tutorials mentioned earlier in this
video but also provides steps to quickly
get started with specific features and
background information about a specific
page component
now that we know what interactive
tutorials are let's follow one together
you can find the interactive tutorials
from the documentation via a guide me
button we'll do this one create a Linux
VM instance in compute engine as you can
see the tutorial shows you what
specifically you will learn in this case
we'll learn how to enable compute engine
in a cloud project create an Ubuntu
Linux virtual machine in other words a
VM
connect to the VM instance over SSH
and very importantly the estimated time
to complete this tutorial which is four
minutes let's click Start to begin
step one of the four step tutorial is to
enable compute engine API in a cloud
project according to the instructions
we'll need to First select a project or
create a new one
I'll use an existing project test ctd
this part might look different on your
end depending on if you don't have
billing enabled or if you're in a free
trial stage the next step is to enable
the necessary apis see how easily this
enables the apis
let's move on to the next step
two is to create a Linux VM instance
we'll follow the instructions starting
with navigating to the menu and clicking
VM instances which appears under compute
engine
then follow the next instruction create
instance
lets you show me and you'll see that
Spotlight feature we were talking about
earlier showcasing what's a click
next we'll enter an instance name
I'll use the name test instance again
let's use the spotlight feature to help
us find change
okay let's click that
we'll change the following settings on
the public images tab operating system
to Ubuntu
version 2 Ubuntu 18.04 LTS
we'll follow the instructions by
clicking select
and in the firewall section clicking
allow HTTP traffic
finally clicking create
we see our new instance on the VM
instances page
let's click next to move on to the next
instructions
step three is to connect to the VM
instance let's find the VM instance we
created
to find the connect column we'll use
Spotlight and a new CMD dialog opens and
shows that we are connected to the VM
terminal
let's click next to move on
step 4 you'll see a few other
interactive tutorials that allow us to
do more with compute engine like how to
transfer files with VM set up a basic
web server
add a VM address to Cloud DNS
finally you'll see information on how to
clean up the instance so you don't incur
additional charges
we'll follow these instructions we'll go
back to navigation
to compute engine
VM instances
will again use Spotlight to find more
actions
finally we'll choose delete then click
delete again to confirm
finally we can click finish to wrap up
this tutorial
[Music]
there you have it in this video we've
learned about how interactive tutorials
can be very helpful for learning more
about Google Cloud if you enjoyed this
video please make sure to like this
video and click the Subscribe button to
watch more videos like this
[Music]